[Musica]
sono
un piccolo paesino ai piedi dell'etna
provincia di capra di catania
diciamo che appena nato cui già
abbastanza sveglio per accorgermi che
nella mia famiglia comandavano i grandi
a me questa cosa non piaceva e iniziai a
ribellarmi e anche a boscaglie di santa
ragione a tutti i componenti più grande
della mia famiglia e la situazione
sociale familiare
a quel tempo era drammatica e noi vi io
ai miei fratelli venivamo sbattuti già
del primo mattino ore di casa
rientravamo la sera si pensa alla sera
non trovavamo non ha da mangiare
andavamo a letto mangiando un po di pane
bagnata nell'uso coroni qualche salafia
di limone e cui fu bocciata in prima
elementare è sfociata anche in seconda
elementare a 9 anni per la mia famiglia
era già abbastanza grande e di mandare a
lavorare in un cantiere di muratura a
trasportare sacchi di cemento dice
quante cala di 50 kg
questa cosa può fare inorridire ma a
quel tempo e lavoro minorile era la
norma insomma nella mia terra in seguito
a causa della separazione delle vie
genitori emigrati al nord fu rinchiuso
collegio in collegio mi ritrovai di
circondate da tutti questi bambini ben
educati che parlavano italiano parola in
dialetto mi chiamavano the room iniziali
per farmi rispettare
asteriti a tirar fuori la mia
aggressività
scappai dal collegio fui ripreso e in
seguito la mia famiglia aumento quello
che rimaneva dalla mia famiglia decise
di riprenderli in casa in casa a trovare
più difficoltà economiche iniziai a
infrangere la legge
all'inizio commettendo piccoli reati poi
facile guadagno come si suol di iniziai
ad alzare il tiro fin quando nel 1972 fu
arrestato durante una rapina
e così conobbi il carcere minori
l'impatto col carcere minorile fu
drammatico con una vera e propria scuola
di crimine era periodo delle rivolte
metrò e mischiati una di queste rivolte
nei anni 70 è collegato ho letto di
contenzione spenti per ben sette giorni
legato in questo letto giurai a me
stesso che quando sei uscito dal carcere
inserire indicato con tutti il tutto
cosa che feci uscì dal carcere cessi la
strada della devianza della criminalità
fin quando nel 1992
fui arrestato fu deportato nell'isola
dell'asinara sottoposta al jimmy tortura
del 41 bis e poi in seguito divenne
definitivo l'ergastolo un bel giorno
della
a prendermi in cella che condivideva con
altre gli ascolani mi portarono
l'assenza di isolamento perché userò né
una cella voti userò nel lato cancello e
lo spioncino per un anno sei mesi e non
poté più parlare vedere altre persone
quindi fu un periodo bruttissimo nella
mia vita
caddi in depressione e le condizioni
igieniche disastrose tra un troppi da
bucato e accesso alla turca metteva una
bottiglia di plastica ma i topi con quei
diritti ne vado circa 1 e l'idea è
spesso mi capitava di vederli
gironzolare per la mia cella
un giorno mi scrisse insegnato
impressione mi propose l'idea di
iniziare a studiare
i disturbi io gli risposi ma è
adesso se non posso quello che gira in
quel calcio è cosa faceva contrari libro
mi disse guarda in studio c'è la trova
le scuse o strappo pace che di libri e
così inizia a studiare sono che lavora
censura spesso queste lettere pagine di
libri strappate venivano portati dalla
censura perché pensavano che
erano pizzini messaggi mafiosi però le
difficoltà che trovai nello studio di
pietro
il motivo è la forza per uscire un po
dalla depressione e poi per fortuna ne
fossero regime di 41 bis e fui portato
in alta sicurezza poter poter avere i
libri ma ovviamente
[Musica]
tutti noi a studiare sempre da
autodidatta ricerca dei contrari
volontari eccetera
la mia vita è stata diciamo contenute
era senza speranza con lanna fra essere
cattiva colpevole da sempre è spesso
insomma pensavo di al suicidio chi è con
l'ergastolano potenziale uscire dal
carcere
no è impiccato secolo tanti pensano che
chi si toglie la vita in carcere non ama
la vita invece penso che è al contrario
che spesso che si tagliano a ripe
carcere e perché ama così tanto la vita
che non va pure deve appassire in quel
modo senza speranza ecco io ho vissuto
per ben 25 anni sapendo che di mensa è
riuscito sfogo del cavaliere
cos'è che mi ha dato la forza di
continuare a lottare
innanzi tutto l'amore della mia figlia
della mia famiglia la mia compagna
continuava spessa di più devi vivere e
arrivano in punto di riferimento per i
tuoi figli e quindi mi senti
condannato anche per amore tutti uguali
a vivere senza senza speranza
lo studio diciamo che è stato importante
nemmeno nel mio percorso lavora la mia
famiglia anche ma quello che veramente è
aiutato sono state le relazioni le
relazioni sociali ecco quel 19
diciamo che mi hanno stimolato a
cambiare ea migliorarmi ma non è facile
perché poi cassano vuole che diventi
buono vuole solo che tu fai il buono
ecco perché probabilmente facile in
italia non funziona
però io ho continuato a lottare
ovviamente migliorando
prova e altri tipi di difficoltà era
diventato un detenuto scomodo perché
carcere ha paura delle prigioniere che
studia sogna e scrive ma quando
prigionieri comincia a conoscere i suoi
diritti poi poi continuare a lottare per
l
caldo e quindi era diventata un detenuto
scomodo un detenuto che scrivevo i
giornali che mi relazionano con
intellettuali iniziali della battaglia
diventa in un attivista per la
produzione della pena dell'ergastolo
ho cercato di coinvolgere persone e
sterili rituali uomini e donne dello
spettacolo
l'incontro poi il commodore esperienze
da papa giovanni xxiii è stato
fondamentale nel mio percorso mi ricordo
appunto quando
una di queste volontarie a nadia
bizzotto disabile in sedia a rotelle
mira a trovare al carcere di spoleto
io non giorno mi disse ma guarda che tu
facendo alimentare
buon anno cercando di migliorarmi mi fai
del male perché qua ci devo vivere ci
devo morire non mi posso permettere il
lusso di diventare buono io devo essere
cattivo il carcere lo purtroppo per
sopravvivere
[Musica]
ti puoi permettere il lusso di diventare
buona eco però poi il bene contagioso ma
volta che farò incontri non è poi più
fare a meno che fortuna poi seguito
dopo vari tentativi dopo 25 anni nel
gastro ostativo è stato tramutato in
quello ordinario segnalando la
possibilità di uscire prima permesso
premio
poi in semilibertà aiuto anche se sono
condizionale in una struttura unica topo
giovanni xxiii
cerco di dare una mano parzialmente
tentò delle mediane ormai ho fatto in
passato facendo facendo del bene ecco
questa può con gli assaggi di modellare
e che tutti possano cambiare
a parte quelli che pensano in contrario
richiede dentro stimolo per cambiare per
migliorarsi e soprattutto l'amore e
l'affetto lega un affetto sociale questo
loro secondo me è stato quello che mi ha
veramente aiutato e stimolato a fare una
rivoluzione copernicana interiormente
carcere così come
in italia purtroppo non è non è nel
cinema diciamo è piuttosto alla malattia
e perché una pena che fa male e poi fa
ma dalla stessa società perché non tutti
sono condannate all'ergastolo unisce ed
esce peggiore di quando è entrato